las autoridades de sri lanka ordenaron a
las fuerzas de seguridad que disparasen
para detener el estallido de violencia
en el país donde a pesar del toque de
queda cientos de personas tomaron las
calles de colombo para exigir la
dimisión del presidente gotabaya
rajapaksa y en rechazo a la brutalidad
policial
la dimisión de may in the rye apax a el
ex primer ministro ha sido algo bueno la
gente está muy contenta pero eso no es
lo único queremos que todo el clan
rajapaksa se vaya porque son muy muy
corruptos y náuticas ya su cara
pedimos en esta protesta de hoy que se
emprenden acciones legales contra ma jin
da raia pasa por incendiar este país y
por utilizar matonismo contra la gente
que protestaba
algunos manifestantes prendieron fuego a
un hotel de lujo que al parecer
pertenece a un pariente de rajapaksa
otros bloquearon la vía principal al
aeropuerto de colombo para evitar que
alguna persona lea la raia pacsa salga
del país según testigos y la policía
disparó al aire en dos lugares para
dispersar a las turbas que intentaban
quemar vehículos una situación que
preocupa a las naciones unidas- hasta
las autoridades incluido el personal
militar desplegado en apoyo de las
fuerzas de seguridad deben actuar con
moderación en la vigilancia de la
situación y garantizar que las medidas
adoptadas en el contexto del estado de
excepción cumplan con las normas
internacionales de derechos humanos y no
se utilicen para reprimir la disidencia
u obstaculizar las protestas pacíficas
el poder del clan raya pacsa se ha visto
sacudido por meses de apagones y escasez
de productos esenciales en la peor
crisis económica de sri lanka desde su
independencia en 1948